[Music]
and there's almost former presidents
Obama and Joe Biden now one of the
things that's exciting about this is
that after this there is a transfer the
nuclear codes I'm a gentleman always
follows the presidents everywhere he
goes he has the nuclear codes and the
president keeps on them a little thing
that that is that it contains the
nuclear codes which is why they're not
allowed to do their own dry cleaning but
in a little bit Trump is going to get a
new set of nuclear code and Obama's
won't work anymore so that's just one of
the many sort of fun little you know
peel back the curtain moments that makes
this all so exciting I don't think
there's anybody better more equipped to
handle nuclear codes than Trump because
if you if you watch The Apprentice and
how he approaches things the man has a
smartness focus laser focus it's a very
sort of laser Cody masters yeah and
actually he gets to say his trademark
you're fired when right yeah bombs North
Korea Iran be your fire that is gonna be
exciting how fun would it be if he
looked at Obama and said you're fired is
responsible for making this all happen
that's right wizard ear taking his
victory lap it's just great it is a
strange moment right now because I think
a lot of people thought that this
couldn't possibly be something we'd ever
actually watch even on the slow march
towards it and here we are in the midst
of it and there's Eric checking for any
predator Eric gonna be very aware that
this is a special moment does not want
anyone breaking into the area of the
prairie dog fort what we might have been
a sign of patriotism oh I thought that
was very fast I thought that was and
that would have fallen on Eric
he was supposed to have his eyes locked
in that area